one estimate this week said that GDP
could shrink by quarter if the strict
measures last until June and that is
causing some to wonder how sustainable
the current situation is well to talk
more about this we're joined now by the
man who led the Bank of England through
the last major financial crash the
former governor Lord Mervyn King thank
you very much for being on the program
this morning Lord King how do you think
the current fallout economic fallout
from the coronavirus will compare with
that crash back in 2008 I think they're
very different the current problems are
one the lost income is an output from
the lockdown secondly the indirect
consequences of the lockdown in terms of
not just of output but the well being
and indeed health because this is spread
right across the economy and the third
and perhaps the most worrying is the
potential loss of what economists called
productive capacity that is the
businesses that we will need to
regenerate the economy if they go out of
business and fail during the lockdown
because the government's measures don't
work as intended that will be a
permanent impact on our ability to
produce so I think everything will
depend on whether the government's
measures work as intended and of course
from the interview that we did earlier
where that alex sharma and those loans
not necessarily getting through to the
companies and requesting them as well
and it's clear that you have some real
concerns about the impact of the
lockdown how long do you think
realistically it can go on for I don't
think it's possible that simple
timeframe on it but I think the
government has a very difficult judgment
to make in balancing these consideration
and I think it's very important that we
realize that the science does not tell
us what we must do science informs the
judgment but government has to make a
difficult difficult balancing judgment I
think given that a vaccine is a long way
away an exit strategy is going to be a
process of trial and error I think it's
sensible for the government to explain
this very clearly I think it makes sense
to adopt measures which reflect the need
to keep some element and that may be a
large element of social is
see while recognizing that social
distancing is not the same thing there's
a total lockdown if we can allow schools
young people some businesses to start up
then while maintaining social distancing
then I think we achieve our objectives
but it's bound to be a process I think
of trial and error it's interesting to
hear you mention some of the suggestions
that people have made about potentially
reopening or lifting restrictions and
parts at the lockdown and you mentioned
schools there do you think that could be
one way too early way to ease the
lockdown or how about this report that
we've heard about showing that perhaps
people in their 20s
it may be allowed to resume almost
normal activities now these are
judgments which any of the government
can take science doesn't tell you what
is the right thing to do but I think it
would be sensible for the government to
be very clear about the difficulty of an
exit strategy I don't think it's
sensible just to tell us all to stay
indoors I think with the government can
rely on the common sense of people and
say to them look these are the
challenges we don't have a vaccine there
is no simple treatment once we start to
relax the intense restrictions of the
current lockdown we do run a risk that
there will be more infection spreading
it's sensible to try this amongst those
groups of the population that are not
apparently as adversely affected as the
elderly and those with existing health
conditions in order to start a process
of trial and error because to maintain
the lockdown as its own costs it's not
just economic cost but cost in terms of
the health and well-being of those
affected by it
do you think then there's a tipping
point where the risk of allowing the
virus to spread a little more is
outweighed by the negative consequences
of the lockdown I don't think it's
possible to make a precise judgement and
I don't like prices like the tipping
point what I would say is that I think
the the best weapon the government has
in this position and it's a very
difficult position for government let no
one be any doubt about it there is no
easy answer is for the government to be
very honest about this
than open and explained the difficulties
and I think the best weapon the
government has is probably the common
sense and instinct of self-preservation
of the British public and now of course
whatever happens there's going to be a
major economic rebuilding effort after
we are finally emerging from what we're
in at the minute and after the last
crash there was a decade of austerity to
follow we just spoke to care star mother
who said that can't be allowed to happen
again but in your view will there need
to be some kind of austerity whether
it's spending cuts or tax risers to try
and recover or do we need to actually
just get used to living with a lot more
debt well I don't think we should worry
today about the extent to which the
national debt will rise provided we can
start to get the economy back to
function sooner rather than later once
we get into say next year and we see
that by how much the national debt has
risen then we just have the opportunity
to run a prudent fiscal policy in order
that slowly and gradually over time the
ratio of that debt to our national
income will fall back to the levels we
have today I think it is worth adding
that one of the benefits of being
prudent about the public finances and
the last bit is that we're in a position
today where it's much easier to absorb a
significant rise in the national debt
and in the interview with the Business
Secretary Locke Sharma he told us that
just 1.4 percent four thousand two
hundred applications for the business
loan scheme had actually been granted it
seems like quite a low number an
alarming number are you concerned about
that or do you think the economy will be
able to rebound quite quickly at once
we're through this pandemic I am worried
about it because the economy will
recover quickly only if we can keep the
businesses that existed at the beginning
of it still functioning and still able
to pick up the reins when the epidemic
is over and I think the worry and it's a
worry not just about the business loan
scheme and the economic policy in
general it's also worried about testing
is that the issue is not about
high-level decisions of what politicians
say it
about making things happen on the ground
and I do think for example that if we
find so few business loans being granted
something has gone wrong I did think
myself that it was a mistake to close
the local bank branches that could have
been able to function with social
distancing to respond to the queries and
claims that the business interruption
loan scheme because as we learnt in 2008
the banking system is an essential part
of the economy just as the health system
we see today is so that's one of the
areas where I think we do need on the
ground to worry about the delivery of
the programs I think this is not a time
to quibble about the policies announced
by the government it is a time to make
sure that what is supposed to happen
actually gets delivered on the ground
okay Lord Mervyn King thank you very
much for being on the show you this
morning thank you thank you